[Music]
thank you
so time then for the Press preview we're
about to take a look at Monday's front
pages and tonight we'll check out the
headlines with the economics editor at
The Spectator Kate Andrews and
journalist and author Rachel shabby good
to see you both that we'll chat in a
moment after we've had a look at some of
those front pages for you why don't we
begin with the Metro leading on Boris
Johnson's claims that he has a 50-page
dossier that will clear him of any
wrongdoing with regards to party Gates
same story on the front of the eye it
says prime minister Rishi sunak has
postponed the announcement of several
key policies because of the publication
of the documents the time says an
independent report due to be released
tomorrow will reveal that the Met police
force faces being broken up if it
doesn't rapidly overhaul its toxic
culture
UBS has agreed to buy credit Swiss for
3.25 billion dollars as Regulators
attempt to prevent the collapse of the
Swiss banking system it's the lead in
the Ft according to the guardian Health
unions are preparing their nurses to
return to strike action with voting on
the five percent pay rise offer on a
knife edge but Delhi Express says
European judges are on the brink of
backing down over their ruling
preventing Asylum Seekers being sent to
Rwanda
that story also leading the Daily Mail
along with a new picture of the Princess
of Wales with her three children
released for Mother's Day and the Star
Wars of Britain is set to face a Polar
Plunge with temperatures dropping to -9
in some places and uh snow forecast
and don't forget you can scan the QR
code that you see on screen during the
program at check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
discussing them to discuss them I'm
joined tonight by the economics editor
at The Spectator Kate Andrews and
journalist and author Rachel shabby very
nice to see both this Mother's Day
thanks for taking the time this evening
and let's get cracking shall we starting
Rachel with the front of the Metro their
headline boris's deadly dossier we're
going to hear his defense tomorrow it's
a 50-page file and he's going to rely on
these WhatsApp messages just that just
explain more
apparently he is I have to say I think
that's a very
um unfortunate headline given how deadly
things were at the time when all these
parties were going on at Downing Street
and everyone else was on District
lockdown measures but yes Boris Johnson
says he has this 50-page dossier that
will prove once and for all conclusively
that he
didn't know and that he didn't mislead
Parliament uh when he said that no
regulations were broken
um once it was revealed that all those
parties were going on
in Downing Street as I say around those
that time when the rest of us were under
the strictest uh lockdown measures so
this is ahead of the Parliamentary
committee which is uh looking into the
lockdown breaches which is meeting on
Wednesday
um and it's expected to have a four hour
um televised
um meeting where Boris Johnson will be
appearing and have to answer their
questions
um whenever this comes up I mean I do
think instantly of all the families
who've lost loved ones at this time and
what this must be like to have that
constantly come up with Boris Johnson
making these claims and I also think
about all those whistleblowers actually
who were so discomforted and so unnerved
and unsettled by what was going on as
they claim in in Downing Street that
that they they felt they had to speak
out
um it does seem like there's a a lot of
evidence
um both from those whistleblowers but
also actual pictures
um suggesting that
um he was aware those measures were
breached but as we say
he's got this dossier and he's going to
present it to the committee on Wednesday
yeah and Rachel very quickly before we
get Kate's thoughts on this which way do
you think it's going to go this week for
Boris Johnson
I mean Boris Johnson
um people who are at one of the parties
said
that he was overheard saying that it was
the UK's most unsocially distanced party
right that's what he said there are
pictures of him
standing in very crowded Gatherings with
booster and about
um
it's sort of Beggars belief that he
wants us to think that he didn't know
um when he's saying things like that and
when there are pictures of him doing
things like that so I hope it doesn't go
well for him
okay well the front of the eye says it's
going to be a crunch week Kate for Boris
Johnson his spokesperson is saying the
evidence will show that he did not
knowingly mislead Parliament um what are
your thoughts on all of this
so the really important question here is
not whether or not partygate happened as
Rachel says we have photos we have many
photos at this point fines have been
issued we know that partying was taking
place inside Downing Street when it was
illegal for the rest of us to at points
even be you know sitting on a park bench
together or
certainly having friends and family into
our home the question is whether or not
Boris misled the House of Commons and
this this argument that he's going to
fight may be made on a very technical
point and and the front of the papers
are suggesting that he's going to claim
that it was
um you know the language and it was the
advice of people that he claims were
very senior around him that we're
suggesting to the language that he ended
up using in the House of Commons that
that may ends up being a technical
argument and of course Boris Johnson is
going to want to use the politics around
this most notably Sue gray who
originally oversaw the partygate report
now planning to go work for Kia stomer
and the labor party he's going to want
to build up that narrative as are his
supporters that this whole thing is
unfair from the start but the big
question isn't whether or not it
happened we know it did it's whether or
not he misled Parliament and if he is
found guilty of doing so he's in
political trouble uh if they want to
suspend him and there's a vote in the
House of Commons where she sunak has
already said that uh he'll give a free
vote on that so people can use their
conscious to vote for that make of that
what you will from the current prime
minister uh and also he could even be
looking at a recall vote depending on
how that suspension played out and and
what that finding was so uh we're kind
of at the start of the process now
depending on what the Privileges
committee decides there could be a much
longer Saga that continues on that
determines Boris Johnson's political
Faith yeah it's going to be quite a week
isn't it um let's move on to another
topic and uh the Rwanda plan uh Rachel
the front of the Daily Express is saying
that European judges are on the brink of
backing down this is over their ruling
preventing Asylum Seekers being sent to
Rwanda
yeah well that's what Zoella Brotherman
um has revealed
um last night so that's off the back of
what was a pretty stomach turning
actually publicity trans stunt trip that
she took to Rwanda which
um uh her cheerleaders in the right-wing
press reported because they were the
only ones who were invited uh to attend
with her and I suspect
uh that this is a way of keeping the
story on the front pages for one more
day according to her the European Court
of human rights which you'll recall they
um issued an injunctions that stopped
um last summer those planes uh that were
about to deport people who let's
remember or vulnerable
um Asylum Seekers fleeing Wars
persecution and worse
um those planes were grounded because of
an injunction from the European Court
human rights she's now saying they might
back down uh the government wants to put
through a bill the illegal migration
bill that would allow ministers to
ignore the court anyway
um and so that's the sort of threat
they've got hanging over the European
Court in strasbour but I guess this is
another one of those things where you
know I'm now saying very sort of boring
legal things
um what we're talking about are the most
vulnerable people on Earth some of of
them
um who we have Zoella Brotherman
dreaming of putting them on a plane and
deporting them uh to Rwanda when we have
a
legal Duty
um to process any and all Asylum claims
made here but also
kind of person dreams of that why would
we want that and why is it dominating
our front pages in this disgusting way
Kate
so Rachel makes the important point that
this is the perspective of the Home
Secretary who wants her deportation plan
to go ahead and she's saying that
progress is being made if progress were
being made with the European Court of
Human Rights I don't actually think that
would be the most surprising news in the
world in the sense that there are a lot
of people out there including legal
experts who think that the European
Court of Human Rights would be more
hesitant to overrule primary legislation
from a government which is what this
government is hoping to bring in rather
than try to work with the rules it has
now it made very clear when it brought
in this illegal migration bill that the
idea was to change legislation so that
would stop happening I mean I very much
agree with Rachel's sentiment about the
ethics around this
um but in in terms of what might
actually be overruled I I think the
bigger question around this is the
practicality of it it is still
completely unclear if a country like
Rwanda will take more than a few hundred
people and it remains very unclear given
how broken broken the UK Asylum system
is currently whether or not the
government is in any position to process
people within 28 days and Deport them
and what's going to happen practically
speaking when it is clear that people
are showing up from war-torn countries
afraid for their lives and we're putting
them trying to put them on planes to a
third country a lot of practical
questions in my opinion
um alongside the technical legal ones
okay all right so I'm just going to get
one more story in before the break and
it's our lead story tonight uh UBS
acquiring credit Swiss Rachel
um the bank is 167 years old it's one of
uh 30 main Global Banks and it was vital
that some sort of rescue deal was done
wasn't it
well apparently it was
um also vital so they were rescued in
this emergency two billion pound deal as
you've been reporting this evening
um and and and for the reasons that you
just stated because it is one of the
world's largest banks and you know there
were concerns that the lack of
confidence in this bank would have a
ripple effect uh throughout the global
banking system
does kind of make you a bit anxious that
this sort of vulnerability is happening
all over again and then we have these
sort of massive government-backed
bailouts of banks who are considered too
big to fail but you know not so long ago
failed spectacularly and we all had to
bail them out then so it does sort of
raise an echo I'm not saying the same
thing is going to happen again I'm just
saying it's odd that have that having
happened once
um the regulations that are in place
aren't sufficient to prevent this
happening again yeah you make a very
good point and Rachel credit Swiss has
had all sorts of problems hasn't it over
the last uh few years it's got itself
into all sorts of hot water
despite lessons that we all learned
after the financial crash
and that's
the consult if there were all these
regulations which by the way our own
government is has a bill going through
Parliament now to try and ease if there
were all those regulations in place why
is a bank like Credit Suisse which is so
big why is it getting itself into such
hot water why is it you know being given
a credit line a few weeks ago but that
credit line wasn't enough
um to stop the damage to stop its share
prices plummeting to stop that sort of
um leeching out of any confidence in
that bank resulting in a in a bailout it
does raise lots of questions
um about actually were any of those
Lessons Learned or are they all now
being rapidly forgotten and dumped yeah
um uh we'll get your thoughts Kate uh in
the next hour if that's all right we're
squeezed for time um I'll be interesting
to find out your thoughts and Analysis
on that uh coming up in a moment plenty
more from the papers including this
story it's on the front of the Guardian
their headline health union members in
push to reject NHS pay deal uh chatty
about that next
[Music]
thank you
welcome back part two of The Press
preview Kate and Rachel are still with
us
um let's have a look at the front page
of the Guardian Kate um a deal uh was
reached wasn't it between union bosses
and ministers regarding uh the NHS pay
deal but it could be undone by this
group called NHS workers say no tell us
about this
it's a cross-union group that's
campaigning against the deal that's been
struck between ministers and Union
Representatives that deal which would
see one-off payments
um especially for covid and the efforts
done there given to a range of six
unions including the Royal College of
Nursing and then a five percent pay
raise uh from uh next year has to be
voted on by the members of course and
this group is saying you should reject
it and you should keep up with the
strikes uh the I think the the reality
the political reality here is that the
government is adamant that it is not
going to give inflation linked pay
raises because they see the headline
rate of inflation coming down so rapidly
this year and actually the information
we got from the budget from the officer
budget responsibility which has one of
the most optimistic forecasts for
inflation that I've seen which is that
it's going to get very close to the
bank's Target of two percent by the end
of this year is actually going to
empower the government on that position
so it's not going to come close to that
11 Mark it's not planning to do that and
the question is whether or not union
members decide that this five percent is
okay from now on looking at where that
headline inflation rate is expected to
go to or whether or not they're going to
campaign for more uh yeah Rachel many
members are angry that it falls short of
that of that 19 that they were
originally demanding I see the guardian
here has quoted one clinical nurse
saying it's an insulting offer it goes
nowhere near what we set out to achieve
interesting this tension isn't it
between the workers and the and the
union leaders
oh yeah absolutely and it's worth
pointing out about inflation that you
know that the damage has already been
done the prices are not going to come
down
um and so I guess for these
um start NHS staff including nurses who
you know this is this like an
extraordinary strike
um they have never been on strike in
their entire history at the Royal
College of nurses so it shows you how
profound the crisis is and of course you
know they a lot of the nurses being
interviewed over the last few weeks have
said look we don't expect 19 it's a
starting offer but you know what they're
being offered is nowhere near that
starting offer and what they're worried
about is not just the fact that they
cannot scrape by on these appalling
wages which is true and the wages have
stagnated for at least a decade but it's
also that they fear that the that it
will affect retention that staff will
continue to leave they'll continue to be
this Mass Exodus from the NHS but also
it'll be very difficult to recruit new
staff as well under such terms so you
can see why they have such concerns and
you can see you know if they've made
this huge decision reluctantly to go on
strike they're unlikely to settle really
for such a poultry offer but Kate do you
not think that if you you know if you if
you join a union you have to put your
faith in the union leaders to to do the
right thing on your behalf
uh I'm not sure that's the reason every
person will be formally signing up to
the union I'm sure there's a lot of
range of views amongst members as to
what the union reps are are actually
negotiating I suspect the union reps
have figured out that the government is
not going to come close to that 11
Target because they are concerned about
a wage spiral they're they're concerned
about the fact that giving that kind of
headline inflation pay raise could
actually make things worse in the future
now we can dispute that but I think
that's very much the government's
thinking on the matter and so they're
thinking that five percent might be
actually quite a compromise from the
government's perspective at this point
that they've been on strike for months
now on and off and and the question is
how long do you keep doing that
especially with the NHS waiting list as
it is at 7.2 million without at this
point hundreds of thousands of
appointments being canceled at some
point you really do have to seriously
come to the table and it seems that the
union reps do you think this is the
moment